he is accused of staging car accidents
ripping off insurance companies and
running a major crime ring
now authorities say william mize has
vanished this evening the u.s marshal
asking for your help
and finding him there's a cash reward up
for grabs the i-team's vanessa murphy
continues
our vegas fugitive series
[Music]
william mize loves three things
according to this deputy u.s marshal
money his legacy and his now deceased
pet
the jet-setting chihuahua would be
decked out in jewels and
always by the side of his owner who's
now a fugitive
this guy sees himself as a godfather of
like a white-collar prime family
and everybody has to obey him or there's
going to be consequences
this deputy u.s marshal asked us to
protect his identity due to the nature
of his work
finding people on the run like mice he
knows the law he's very smart guy
he's one of the smartest people i've
come across to because it's
the amount the paper trail that he knows
how to cover is really impressive
federal prosecutors say mize staged car
crashes
falls and other accidents in five
different states including nevada
causing insurance companies to pay out
more than six million dollars for the
fraudulent claims
if you wonder why your car insurance is
high is part of the problem
mize and 21 others were indicted in 2018
most of them spent time in prison
records show some are still in custody
like his wife
but the now 59 year old man vanished
halting his court proceedings if you
ever came in contact with this guy
check your credit history because he's
really good about using other people's
identities
he does have a history of turning very
violent if he doesn't get his way
he tells the it mize was last seen at
total wine in henderson
in 2019 and he looked like he was
dressed for a boat ride
one of his other passions but he left
without buying anything because he may
have realized he was spotted
i think it was kind of quick he realized
that he made a mistake there but this
guy is usually very smart that doesn't
make mistakes
he says mize has family in the area and
the u.s marshals believe he remains in
southern nevada
he faces numerous charges including mail
and wire fraud
and newer charges in connection with
being a fugitive
vanessa murphy 8 news now there is a
25-hundred dollar reward for any
information leading to the capture of
mize if you have information you can
call the u.s marshal's office
there's the number down bottom of your
screen 702-388-6355